I'll start there actually because
directing your first feature is a huge
feat that should be celebrated two
question on that what is something about
your shitz creek directing experience
that you found coming in handy on good
grief but then also what is a learning
curve you experienc directing your first
feature you know what I think it wasn't
so much the direct I mean I I I honed
skills directing episodes of my TV show
for sure I think more than anything else
it was watching the way that my dad and
Katherine
O'Hara handled themselves on set because
a set is governed
by the top of the call sheet so to speak
and when an actor is in in the case of
my TV show actors are so generous and so
collaborative and so
wanting the experience to go smoothly
and and well and for it to be enjoyable
for people the the ripple effect the
domino effect of that can be felt
through the entire experience so yes I I
I needed to hone skills in terms of what
it is to be a director on a set and what
that means but more than anything else
and I don't want to say more importantly
but it is a significant part of it
running a set and knowing how you want
it to be how you want it to feel how you
want your actors to feel how you want
your crew to feel that to me was the
greatest gift that I was given from
shitz Creek and then in terms of a
learning
curve you know I think there are breaks
when you make television well not really
there's a weekend when I guess there's a
weekend in making movies anyway well
it's just ultimately it's a long is it
longer no it's not
um it's the it's not the same uh It's
Tricky I don't know it's it's about
negotiation ultimately every day is a
negotiation every day you are in pursuit
of protecting the movie you want to make
and all you are up against are the
elements you know we were there's a
scene in at the end of the movie on a
ferris wheel we thought we were going to
get an entire day to shoot on the ferris
wheel they came to us the night before
and said not only will you not get any
time on the ferris
wheel the time you will get cuz we were
supposed to rent
it cut two night before you were no
longer renting the ferris wheel you have
to go on the ferris wheel with all the
rest of the tourists which is fine if
you had pre-planned for that but what
ended up happening was they we had to
prep the ferris wheel pod with a camera
and a team and a light they had to do
that while the tourists were on the
ferris wheel then the wheel came the Pod
came back around we had to get on the
Pod and start acting as it was going
around so there was you know there's
like it's the her that make the
adventure worthwhile the first thing
that I saw was I'm like that is a
production hurdle
right script I'm like God help you uhhuh
yeah yeah yeah no shut you know why
don't we walk around some Mones why
don't we get on on a ferris wheel in the
middle of Paris you know we shot for the
stars and it worked out it didn't work
out I want to go back to where you
started and I'll pose this to you Hames
and Ruth because I love talking about
the value of a good number one on the
call sheet and a leader on set so to
make danam BL now what is something you
appreciated about him in that respect
that you are excited for more actors to
get to experience when they work with
him as a director in the future I didn't
know that was all going on with about me
first okay what I didn't know the fer
did you know that all that about the
ferris ferris wheel thing that we had OD
didn't see it's not amazing um Ferris
wheel I don't know uh you know what a
set that is safe and kind M it sounds so
simple to why isn't it that simple
always don't understand that the will
isn't there sometimes and the will has
to be there and everything that Dan said
about being on set and the top of the
call sheet and how the energy filters
through never a true word was said it
really
matters and I mean sometimes it's kind
of scary that um you know the that the
the welfare of a set can depend on you
know someone's personality unfortunately
that is sometimes the way it is it
shouldn't be that way but luckily Dan
understands all of that and and and that
that you know all you want to do anybody
who's working on a on a on a set wants
to do their job the best they can um
safely and with kindness and hopefully
enjoy themselves you know and that is
exactly the set that um that you know
you want to come to work you want to
come to work every day and that's what I
felt on this one and I think that
generosity actually you know I'm excited
for actors but also crew members to work
with Dan because I think that generosity
is filtered through the entire
production you know I mean you made a
concerted effort to make sure the food
we were getting every day was good you
know rather than sometimes food on on
film sets isn't isn't always the best
and it was it's a huge deal it means
that everyone's happy and they want to
work you know they want to they they
it's just such a simple thing you feed
feed everyone well and they're and
they're happy
I mean I worked in an environment when I
was in my early days that was where I
felt so in so disrespected in the
workplace undervalued undervalued and
disrespect I guess is what I had
interpreted as under like undervalued
disrespected no I totally get it you
personalize it in a way and you stop
working you stop doing your best because
you think well if nobody
notices and I'm not there's no concerted
effort being made to make me feel
included or like my work is helping here
the the the the the factual truth is you
pull one person away from a film set and
something will change so if you don't
make everyone on that set feel like the
work they are doing is completely
valuable and necessary to the pro
process you're not going to get people
to work as hard because they don't feel
motivated they don't want to come to
work so when people feel like oh what
I'm doing from the food that I'm making
to the lighting that I'm setting up is
crucial they take ownership rightful
ownership over the film that they're
making or the TV show that they're
making and it becomes theirs it's not a
job it's something they have ownership
and stake in and that's I think when you
get
real and especially on things that are
lower budgets you know shitz Creek for
example had no money to it but we got
what we got out of it because everyone
had stake in what we were making and
that was crucial in this project in
anything that I have the have the
privilege of being able to to kind
of a standard that I am able to set so
often as actors you walk into a set
that's already dictate like the the
culture of the set is dictated for you
so when you get that opportunity to set
that bar it's crucial that people walk
away feeling I'm a big believer that
when a set has that quality you could
feel it radiating off the screen and I
felt that Alchemy it creates Alchemy
that's how it doesn't just get created
with just turning up it it takes work
all right I have to wind down with you I
want to squeeze in one spoiler question
cuz I'm obsessed with the third act
scene with Celia imry it's like one of
the most exceptional performance beats
I've seen all year so what is it like
figuring out I guess how best to support
her with an emotional monologue like
that it wasn't supporting it was giving
a platform too and I think Celia is one
of the great actors of her generation
and it was such a thrill to get to work
with her so what I did was create an
environment for her to to be free to do
what she wanted to do as many times as
she wanted to do it and it was easy for
me as it is for a lot of actors when
you're working with wonderful people I
mean it's it's very easy to react and
that's all I had to do in that scene so
I just had to set up the platform for
her to do her thing and just when the
cameras turned around on me it was just
I didn't have to do much um but she was
I remember shooting that scene with her
and no one really knew we didn't
rehearse it um and she
just caught us all by surprise you know
not that we didn't expect it from her
but we didn't know what choices she
would make and there was such
vulnerability and such um stoicism in a
way like I it was miraculous and I just
remember thinking God this is going to
be one of those great scenes I might
have re-watched it a couple of times
congratulations the three of you are
phenomenal together to than you
so